in this video i'm going to talk to you
about biden's new proposed tax plan and
what it means for us as entrepreneurs
and i'll try and break down all
different levels of entrepreneurs and
how these things may affect you all
right and so i uh made a little list uh
of the of the main bullets that i think
everyone should know about all right so
i'm going to give you a little example
of what it is what it means for us and
then at the end what i'm going to do is
i'm going to kind of summarize what i
plan to do to kind of you know mitigate
some of these things that are happening
all right now that being said i've made
other videos on taxes and taxation in
general there are a handful of things
here that very very deeply concern me
and i'll express those when we get to
them all right so let's rock and roll
and if you don't know hi my name is
oxford i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that does 100
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you and i make these videos because
i think they're fun and cool and i think
entrepreneurship is is awesome all right
so lots of love let's see let's rock and
roll so number one uh they're gonna
increase the top marginal tax rate to
39.6 percent after 2022 no big surprise
there they're just gonna make the top
bracket pay more okay number two they're
going to tax long-term capital gains and
qualify dividends with taxable income
over a million dollars at ordinary
income tax rates okay so if you make
over a million bucks a year all of your
capital gains are now being taxed at
again 40 like i just said which double
blows but you know noted do we think
that's going to affect uh how people
invest not as much as i think you would
think because if you have no alternative
you just have to continue to play the
game because you're not going to not
invest the money because of the tax
you're still going to invest and then
you're just going to have to pay the
taxes now what i do think it will do is
it will get a lot of people to not
realize their capital gains because
they're gonna hope for a change in in
leadership which is exactly what i would
definitely just not sell or we recently
you know exited three of our companies
this last year and it was because we
anticipated a capital getting out
because of this but among one of the
reasons was that we anticipated a big
increase in capital gains tax and so we
thought it might be a good time to
recognize some of our our equity all
right so next one is they're gonna treat
transfers of appreciated property by
gift at death as taxable dispositions
okay so basically normally you could you
could give such at death and it wasn't
taxed in this case they will be now
they're going to raise the corporate
income tax to 28
you know which basically bumps it back
from when when trump cut it there's
going to be tax on stock buybacks which
most you guys probably don't need to
worry about impose a 20 minimum on
income and this is probably the biggest
one this is like i mean well it'll
affect me it might not affect a lot of
people but it's a 20 minimum tax on
income okay including unrealized gains
all right which to me is one of the most
insane concepts of all time and i'm
gonna break down this one particularly
at the end of this little bulleted list
because like there's a lot of
consequences that i think for lack of a
better term are [ __ ] insane but i
want to break it down so you can at
least you know at your next cocktail
party or whatever it is like talk
intelligently about it okay next one is
impose minimum term and gift
requirements so it's effective on all
trusts created on or after the date
basically they're just decreasing
write-offs there i'll cover a couple
more of the big ones carried interest so
the private equity guys are now going to
finally pay income tax i think that's
probably a good thing overall uh they're
going to cap deferral of gain from 1031
exchanges for the real estate guys uh
to 500 000 per taxpayer which means like
pretty much if you're a serious real
estate investor you're gonna now not
have that 1031 to like shelter all of
your tax-free gains and if you don't
know what 1031 is it's basically you
sell a house you have the the profit
that you have from the house if you put
it into something that's similar in
nature a similar type of building uh
within a period of time like i think
it's a year then you don't have to pay
taxes you're basically just transferring
it into another building and it
continues and the reason they have those
those uh tax treatments is because you
know the government likes to incentivize
people to continue to rebuild
infrastructure and so real estate and
buildings are a big part of that and so
if they make it incentivizing for
investors to uh to invest in those
places then it means the country as a
whole will continue to upkeep its real
estate it will continue uh to just
overall infrastructure continue gets
built by private money right which is a
good thing for everybody uh but they're
eliminating that we're capping it for
the vast majority of people who do the
most of the volume they're gonna
decrease uh deductions for easement
transactions that's like a kind of a tax
loophole around donating land and things
like that and then
limit the use of donor advice funds for
private donations so basically their
limit how much you're gonna you're gonna
be able to write off off of uh donations
all right there's a whole bunch of other
stuff and they also uh limit the
duration of generation skipping uh
transfer tax exemptions so it's
effective to all trusts which means that
like for the whole concept of like i
want to pass on my wealth to my to my
generations what do the rockefellers do
they're gonna they're gonna cut that
severely if they pass this okay so this
is this is the bill i think that there's
there's there's obviously plenty more
than what you can say in in you know
five minutes but i want to talk about
one aspect in particular i'll i'll
probably talk about two one of them is
gonna be the income tax the second will
be the uh the the corporate uh tax
increase and the third will be uh the
one that i'm most concerned about which
is the uh unrealized capital gains tax
all right so first one you know if
you're going from 37 or i don't even
know what it was 37 to 39.6 is it gonna
make a big difference for you probably
not if you're in that bracket but it is
kind of like boiling a frog you know at
a certain point there's only 100 percent
that someone can take but you know i've
always made in my last video i talked
about how like the real wealth is always
built in growth of equities growth of
the things that you're building right uh
which is one of the things that they're
going to threaten which i'll get to last
the second one is corporate tax right
and so if you have a c corp and this is
in the u.s you can leave the money that
you have in the c corp and pay less tax
as a result so at this point i think
it's 23. don't quote me my account's not
somewhere in there for c-corps and
they're going to bump into 28. where
this becomes a real issue is that if you
take dividends from your company you pay
income tax on the dividends like regular
income tax so you're going to pay 28 and
then 40. so all of a sudden this starts
to like not make as much sense now the c
corp structure makes the most sense if
you plan on continuing to redeploy
capital within the business all right so
if you are playing the game of i want to
increase the value of the corporation
that i own and i'm going to so it's more
efficient for me to have the corporation
pay the 28 percent keep it in retained
earnings and then redeploy it through m
a capital expenses investing in you know
infrastructure things like that they're
going to increase the value of the
business now the vast majority of the
time especially if you're a small
business you don't really have anything
besides merge and acquisitions and again
i said small business so this might not
apply for a lot of people but besides m
a there's not a lot of stuff that you're
going to really play that money for
which is why i think llcs and whatnot
work for most small businesses better
now once you get a little bit more
sophisticated i think c corps can make
more sense but you have to do a cost
analysis on both in terms of how you
plan on redeploying the capital so that
you can in most accounting firms will be
able to do a side-by-side comparison for
you so you can see what your net tax
implications are now i'm a big fan of
not caring at the end of the day because
we're gonna die about about taxes uh on
income but if you're going to get taxed
you can still be smart about it and you
know just do the normal work i wouldn't
i wouldn't uh you know encourage you to
spend a tremendous amount of time
wasting on this stuff rather than
building your business because that's
we're going to build the most of your
wealth now let's get the last one and
then alex will make two recommendations
that i think are going to be highly
controversial and unpopular but i think
would be way more beneficial so the
unrealized capital gains so this is kind
of complicated the way they set it up
all right and a lot of people are behind
and hawing about how this works but
let's just say that your net worth is
100 million dollars okay now a lot of
people might be tuning in i'd be like
wow if i'm at 100 million dollars like i
won't care and you might but you might
not and i'll tell you why it's like
right now the reason you get 200 million
is because
you believe in the american dream and
you believe in the american dream
because you believe that opportunity is
endless and what happens is and this is
why i'm very afraid of this particular
tax is that it makes it much more
difficult to attain and so what it will
essentially do is is massively massively
massively affect how much people can
basically build their net worth too and
i would more or less be okay with that
from a from a cognitive you know from a
from a logical basis excuse me if the
capital were being redeployed through a
an efficient system but the private
sector deploys capital 10 times more
effectively than the government does and
so you're basically taking money out of
people's hands who are very good at
deploying capital and putting it into
people's hands who are very bad at
deploying capital people who work for
the government don't normally have the
best capital deployment skills uh
compared to people who do this for a
living and so that's like kind of like a
systemic concern that i have the other
one is that i think it will kill
innovation because i mean i think this
would be a kiss of death for the u.s
economy and be really honest with you
because we want to be at the cutting
edge of innovation starting new
companies etc where do you think so many
of these you know really exciting you
know startups software companies etc get
their initial funding from wealthy
people and if wealthy people no longer
are incentivized to do that or massively
disincentivized to do that then they
just won't do it or they'll invest
elsewhere on top of that u.s as a whole
will be saving less money while all of
our foreign competitors will be saving
more money and will have the money going
to people who are better at allocating
capital than their governments and so i
think it's a really really really really
bad move just from an economic
standpoint now mind you and i just want
to be really clear i've only voted one
time in my entire life and i regretted
it because it was a waste of time so
just i say this because i i don't think
that my vote matters and everyone's like
if everyone thought that way it's like
don't worry no one not everyone thinks
that way so it doesn't matter i'm not
gonna like somehow make one youtube
video and everyone's gonna suddenly stop
voting because what happens is if fewer
people started voting then the votes
would matter more and more people start
voting right so it's a balancing act
anyways here's how the unrealized
capital gains tax will work this is me
broad brushstrokes okay the the armchair
uh people who read every single word of
the tax proposal you're awesome i love
you and you know by all means put all of
the all of the the corrections in the
comments uh but this is the general gist
okay so let's say you have a 200 million
dollar net worth and the 200 million
dollar net worth is based on a a uh a
10x multiple of a company that you own
that does 20 million dollars a year in
ebitda or earnings all right i'm trying
to keep this simple as hell okay so you
have a 10x multiple on 20 which gives
you 200 million dollars in value now how
they're going to to calculate this i
haven't even read into because i
actually haven't been able to find it i
googled all over and i could find it but
let's just say that that's how it's
being calculated okay and if someone in
the comments does know how it's being
calculated post the formula i'm really
curious so you got 20 million that's
that's coming in uh as ebitda for the
company that you own 100 of just for
math's sake and that's worth 200 million
now let's say that
next year you grow the thing to 25
million even okay and with a 10x
valuation that means that your company
goes to from 200 to 250 million okay in
value assuming you took all of the
profit of your company as a dividend
which is not likely but let's just
assume again to make this simple it
means that you would make 25 million
dollars in income okay that's category
one and then you would have taken your
company from 200 to 250 million so
you've got 50 million here and 25
million here so that was the net
increase in your like net worth ish ish
okay pre-tax ish they want everybody to
pay 20
on unrealized capital gains and so that
extra 50 million 20 of that would be 10
million dollars okay so that's 10 right
to the side and then you've got your
normal income tax of 40
on your 25 all right which is going to
be another 10 okay which means keeping
keeping math keeping math here if you
paid all your taxes up front then you
would pay 25 million sorry 20 million of
your 25 million in taxes
20 out of 25 million in taxes it's an 80
tax rate that's really aggressive now
that's assuming that you don't have some
sort of tech company that doesn't make
any profit because if you did have that
then i don't even know what their plan
is for that situation i think you'd have
to sell stock of your own company to pay
the tax on the increase
and somehow get like it
it would be or you'd have to take loans
against your equity to pay the taxes
it's really shitty the thing that
they're trying to do to soften the blow
here all right because i mean think
about it literally be like overnight 80
tax rates and that's that's with that
example that i gave right it could be it
could be that's it with a really high
cash flow company if you don't have a
high cash flow company that's valued for
other reasons it would basically just
drain you like you'd just drain you
entirely from all your reserves you'd
have to go into debt to continue to own
your company or you'd have to own less
of your company to continue to run your
company so you'd literally be
disincentivizing the founders and
innovators from continuing to grow their
company because if they grew it they get
taxed more before they can pay for it
that being said the little special
caveat that they're trying to do to make
it softer is that it's
it can be spread over nine years all
right so that 10 million dollars could
be spread over nine years so it'd be
like 1.1 million or whatever on top of
your normal income tax right but the
thing is is that it will stack up right
so it's like it's 1.1 so i might pay my
normal you know 10 million on my 25 that
i that i paid in income tax and then i'd
have 1.1 that i'd start paying towards
the 10 million that i owe on the 50
million dollars the thing is is that it
sounds it sounds like okay that's not
that's not as bad it's just because no
one can think in time right because you
just fast forward 10 years and then
you're going to be paying that it just
they're just they're just slowly
bullying the frog uh to get to the point
where where it stacks up on top of
itself because next year you're going to
owe 1.1 and another probably more than
that because if the company grew again
you'd have another you know tax bill
you'd have to pay on top of that and so
hopefully you're seeing it's like mount
it's like mountains of debt basically in
tax that you're gonna have to start
paying and so nine years from now that's
when you're you're you're getting
smashed right because it's going to take
nine years for these payment plans to
stack now obviously that's one assuming
that they pass it to that they don't
repeal it i think the likelihood that it
passes is low but i will tell you this i
think it is one of the scariest tax
bills i've ever seen and it's because
if you disincentivize the very people
who are building the things that grow
this economy it makes the risk that a
founder takes on virtually untenable
it's like when you start a company you
risk failure and you have the the odds
are stacked against you that you will
fail like it's very likely that you're
going to fail and in the in the off
chance that you actually succeed they
will unless you just have a very normal
boring cash flow business which many
businesses are not that way that have
tremendous value they will basically
just bankrupt you and la and stack so
much tax debt on you for things that you
have not realized yet and here's where
it gets worse what if you do that you
pay taxes on capital gains that are
unrealized and then the company goes
under which is also very common you
basically just paid taxes to the
government on stuff you never got ever
and those taxes might actually be the
thing that destroy the business because
you got saddled with that you could
barely pay your own expenses so
the example i gave was a generous one
because a lot of times you're not going
to have you know 25 million dollars a
year that's coming in let's say you have
i'll give you a different example to
really drive this home let's say you had
an exit and you have a hundred million
dollars okay let's just say that that's
your your current net worth and you're
probably pretty good at making money or
allocating capital because you have that
money right and so let's say you get 15
on that your net worth goes up by 15
million and let's say that because you
had your you know exit you know you only
make 2 million bucks doing consulting
stuff whatever so you make 2 million
dollars and you get taxed 40 so that's
800 000 but then you make 15 million
dollars in increased appreciation on
your assets so the 20
minimum tax there would be 3 million
dollars on the 15. that's more than you
made in total and people like well it's
going to spread over nine years it's
like yeah but then next year you're also
gonna have to pay it and then the night
you're after that so like it's going to
stack up and people just can't [ __ ]
do math you have three million dollars
in taxes and you only made two million
and you still have the 800 so you have
1.2 million left and you still owe
another three so you're going to have to
come up with 1.8 million dollars every
year just because you happen to own
stuff and have a successful exit and so
then you start bleeding your 100 million
that you risked everything to get in
order to pay off tax for gains you
haven't realized so you have to sell
stuff just you basically the government
will just force you to sell your
belongings or they put you in prison so
i think it's um i think it is it is one
of the scariest things i've ever seen i
think it destroys the american dream i
think it is against capitalism i think
that the government is a terrible
allocator of capital in general and they
are literally one-tenth as efficient as
the private sector is and so we're just
going to take money out of the hands of
the people who are most effective with
it but that being said i understand i
understand the the inequality that
exists at the top the difficulty that i
have is the psychology around it which
is it's just like every mlm every mlm in
the world you know they show that they
show the number one you know person and
because of survivorship bias people
think that's going to be me stats would
show that it's probably not going to be
but just the hope just that the idea
that you could someday get there is what
inspires the vast majority of
entrepreneurs i think i mean at least me
and i think destroying that incentive
and destroying that vision of what what
could happen would be a really big
detriment i don't have the best solution
i did say i have a couple of ideas and
said these are alex's very unpopular
ideas around taxation i think that and
like people are going to call me crazy
for this but here's two very radical
ideas number one is uh decrease income
tax dramatically to zero percent and
then have an enormous capital gains tax
and the reason for that is because most
people who are poor make money off of
income right most people who are wealthy
make money off of their invested
investments and so that would be a i
think more balanced way of helping you
know then it would still help all of the
basically if you're working you should
get you'd be able to keep all the stuff
that your hands are making for you right
and i feel like that would be a really
interesting balanced approach to the
process right because you're basically
limiting how much people can make
passively from their money and
forcing more people to work so that was
that's that's an idea i'm sure there's
plenty of holes there always are but
that was just one i was like huh that
would be interesting a different idea
that i have is because most of you who
know me know that i'm not a huge fan of
the concept of legacy because you know
you multiply out your generations 5 000
years they won't know who you are just
like you don't know the people who you
came from um and so the idea of legacy
is kind of a myth when you expand it
over a long enough time horizon and
because i think that money ruins people
when you have not earned it the
alternative would be to have basically
like 100 death tax decrease the taxes
dramatically on income and capital gains
throughout the entire life that someone
has but basically eliminate the
transfers of wealth and what that does
is i think it will create a world where
people become significantly more giving
as they get older anyways because they
know they can't take it with them both
in the like we know we can't take it
with us but for some reason we have this
deluded idea that we're going to be able
to pass it on to people and so i think
it would force the people who know that
the government is going to tax them i
don't think that they would want all
that money to go away and so what will
happen is that in the in the end of
their lives they will start giving it
all away and then privately allocating
the money where they are more efficient
than the government is and actually have
a massive improvement in the well-being
of society as a whole and so think about
that as like these these huge wealths
get accumulated and then they just can't
they can't just pass the generation keep
accumulating and accumulating it instead
it just gets boom back and then it helps
everybody else out and so that is that
is actually my best is in my opinion my
best idea that i have uh to fix the tax
system which would be massively decrease
income tax massively decreased capital
capital gains because i would encourage
investment it would encourage people to
work it would mass it would increase the
amount of innovation it would increase
foreign money coming to the company
into the united states in the country
the death tax the fact that you can't
transfer the wealth to you know people
with that you could do 100 you get 90
whatever it is right some big percentage
and i'm sure you could write a little
bit of you know clauses around like
spouses directly or something like that
but basically not down generations i
think that would be a really cool way to
incentivize everybody who accumulates a
lot of wealth to end up giving it away
and the key part that i think makes it
interesting is that because they will
give it away rather than getting it
taxed they will privately allocate the
money where it's more effectively spent
than the government does and i think
that overall would flood the u.s with
pretty probably all the social systems
that it would need um privately funded
more efficiently and probably
alternative educations and things that
the people who make the most money are
passionate about and what's interesting
here too is that the people who make
lots and lots of money first generation
is very very different second and third
generation wealth they talk about all
the time one you know one first
generation builds a second duration uh
maintains that their generation destroys
it and the people who are builders
most times i think is like 85 like don't
quote me but i think it's like 85 of the
the forbes list are self-made and so
people talk about these billionaires
like they're these terrible people but
like they're they're one of us who just
made it right and so giving those people
typically i think start caring about
everyone the wider up you go the higher
up the the because you don't need to
satisfy your needs anymore you're really
just trying to help humanity at this
point and so i think that you'd have the
best most innovative people trying to
make an impact on humanity rather than
leaving a legacy to their very
concentrated family anyways that's
alex's two cents on on joe biden's plan
welcome mozination if you're new most of
the times to talk about business stuff
this one was an exception if you enjoyed
it let me know if you hated it also let
me know keeping amazing i'll catch you
guys next video bye